why did you make me do that look at me  focus on my voice I'm not giving up on  you Jean she was my friend  you're my family jeans no matter what  look  you're special gene  and if you stop fighting that force  inside you  whew Grayson he will possess the very  power of a god  oculus all tell me how we fix this  trough  tell me what to do I don't know what to  do  more they don't understand  they fear and what they fear we seek to  destroy  shoot all Charles tries to protect  I'm scared  when I lose control bad things happen to  people like watch the girl dies  she's still June we can still help her  sometimes you want to believe people are  something that they are not  by the time you realize who they are  it's too late  she's coming  [Music]